The specific objectives
of this lesson are, one,
we'll talk a little bit about
the concept of Epsilon Photography,
and how we can go from that
concept to Coded Photography.
We'll talk, really,
in much more detail about the concept
of Coded Photography itself.
And we'll talk about coded aperture, and
a flutter shutter camera, two specific
types of camera that actually can do a
little bit more than a standard camera.
Of course, both these cameras are
examples of computational cameras that
very interested building for
those support computational photography.
Both of these, the coded aperture
camera, and the flutter shutter camera
are computational cameras that
are partly what we have thinking of,
when we talk about controllable
cameras can be used to capture
images to support the computational
photography pipeline.